sa comédie mathis situations en sort du
buffet depuis 1984 les plus grands
artistes contemporains des peintres des
sculpteurs ont été exposés ici au centre
d'art de tanlay cette année les diables
et les dieux nouvelle exposition
réalisée par des artistes venus de
continents différents
l'occasion pour nous d'évoquer la
fabrication l'élaboration et l'impact
que peut avoir une exposition d'art
aujourd'hui cela fait déjà 45 ans que
dans l'yonne des oeuvres rares activé
fortes viennent chaque année nous
titiller les yeux et l'âme des
expositions annuelles que l'on doit dès
l'origine à louis ii le dic et à la
fidélité du conseil départemental
ancy-le-franc dès 1970 puis à tanlay en
1984 toujours dans les communs du
château pour des artistes hors du commun
comment vous monter une exposition ce
quelque chose qui est plutôt n'en dans
l'affectif intellectuelle française
passe comment ça se passe et bien après
dire ça ne se passe pas cette vierge
essaye de de créer les expositions qui
correspondent à mon et à mes intérêts en
la peinture et la sculpture
donc je suis comme un collectionneur et
je crée une exposition
avec un choix d'artistes qui pourra être
se faire partie de ma collection et j'ai
eu la chance de pendant ses nombreuses
années de changer vos collections tous
les ans l'exposition 2015 une
exploration du monde des diables et des
dieux posé sur la frange entre le rite
l'imaginaire et l'ombre et la lumière
d'artistes différents comme cyprien
tokuda kba skate expérience est ce que
si prise jack ma est un prêtre vaudou
une est venu ici dessiner les dieux vous
tous qui l'a titien sont les murs de
tanlay que l'on a récupéré
quand on regarde une avoir de tout coup
d'agra qui est si c'est un personnage
qui nous sommes fixes c'est quand même
très étrange
ils vous regardent alors que vous êtes
musulman sens et le regard des enjeux
concernent des ministres hommes qui est
un des grands patrons doit lui-même a
vécu avec les chamans dans le grand nord
l'ensemble des artistes des gens très
près de la nature très potes très très
près de la vie une vie que barthélémy
toguo a su insuffler à ses diable et
dieu à travers aquarelle lavis encre de
chine et peinture lui qui avait dû
quitter son pays pour échapper à une
carrière de fonctionnaire rêvé par son
père coco fronsac elle aussi à changer
de cap après la lithographie dans les
ateliers parisiens
elle est partie chine et des photos
qu'elle a retravaillé ensuite
et puis sorte de filet d'accompagnement
dès qu une centaine de pièces d'art
primitif venue du monde ans
les artistes sont extrêmement importants
la culture extrêmement important c'est
important parce que ce sont des passeurs
de liberté ce sont deux sont avant tout
des résistants et des résistants contre
tous les systèmes d'ailleurs on le voit
surtout actuellement chaque fois qu'il
ya une dictature la première chose que
l'on fait on va ont supprimé mardi
c'est très important que le public
soutienne les artistes et prennent
conscience de l'importance des artistes
créateurs quelles que soient les
disciples et tout sur la musique la
littérature ou le plastique des artistes
et surtout des oeuvres protégées
partager grâce à l'énergie et à l'amour
de ce collectionneur de toutes les
collections
il vous reste jusqu'au 20 septembre pour
découvrir l'exposition les diables et
les dieux ici à tanlay au centre d'art
jusqu'au 20 septembre